so I think it's become pretty obvious to
anyone
who's paying close attention and being
honest with himself that what you're
seeing is not really a contest between
Republicans and Democrats the left and
right it's a contest between the people
in charge and everybody else it's not
actually partisan in a traditional sense
there's really one party on the big
issue the big issues being economics and
foreign policy there's total agreement
in Washington and so once you understand
that then you can go backward
into recent history and reassess a lot
of the things that you saw through a
very different lens and one of those
things is the imprisonment of the
Democratic governor of Illinois Rod
Blagojevich and in retrospect it's very
obvious that he was sent to prison for
political reasons incarcerated for eight
years on bogus corruption charges his
case is a lot more interesting than most
people understand he's learned a lot he
just responded to the indictment of
Donald Trump this is the Democratic
former governor of Illinois
and he wrote this quote president Trump
fired me freed me and now he's getting
f'd like me weaponized prosecutors are
destroying our country it's time for
republicans and Democrats to stand up
and defend our constitution against
third world politics
really a view that speaks for probably
the majority in this country the former
Governor joins us now Governor thank you
so much for coming on
um so tell us Yuri I think that tweet
kind of summarizes it pretty well but
expand on that a little bit given your
own experience with a similar
prosecution
well I had them as fortunately being
arrested as a sitting Governor at six
o'clock in the morning and when my
little girl's five and 12 years old were
asleep hadn't gotten up yet for school
and then it was a major event and I was
allegedly trying to sell president-elect
Obama's senate seat it was a political
deal Obama started the whole thing said
an emissary to me to talk about a
political deal
the Appellate Court eventually reversed
the sale of the senate seat was a big
lie but Winston Churchill said a lie can
travel halfway around the world before
the truth has a chance to put its pants
on and so I see what they're doing to
president Trump and it's more than deja
vu all over again to me I don't like
what they did to me I would never give
in I fought back and as a result for
political things nobody even alleges I
took a penny they gave me a 14-year
sentence and put me in a higher security
prison well no Governor's been where my
home was a six foot by eight foot prison
cell and I was in there with people who
committed murder because they were
trying to squeeze me and they gave me
this long sentence I truly believe to
bury me and with it the truth because it
was a corrupt prosecution they tried me
twice used an unlawful standard to get
convictions at a second trial when they
couldn't convict me on their fake
charges the first trial and they did it
to a Democrat Governor at the AAA level
what they're doing now to president
Trump at the major league level is not
only frightening but this is probably
I would say the most threatening thing
to our republic since South Carolina
fired shots at Fort Sumner that started
the Civil War this is a very serious
thing and I would say to my fellow
Democrats I was a Democratic governor
the first one to endorse President Obama
I supported Nancy Pelosi when I was a
member of Congress I would say to my
fellow Democrats put your country above
your hatred for Trump and be against
this weaponization of prosecutions by
political people who have uncontrolled
power and are going to destroy our
freedoms
one thing I noticed and thank you for
saying that and I hope you're not the
last Democrat who stands on principle
and defends our system but one of the
things I noticed in your prosecution was
that nobody defended you and once you're
accused of a crime very few people stand
up
or even bother to assess the actual
evidence I was one of them I had no idea
what had happened to you it took me
years to figure it out I'm I'm
embarrassed by that but I wonder if
being accused alone isn't a kind of
sentence for the person accused
what's awfully hard when they accuse you
like that and they did with me they I
was Roger Stone before Roger Stone they
arrested me with SWAT teams around my
house I was a sitting governor and they
did it with a massive press conference
and they said they were quote unquote
stopping a crime spree before it
happened now they played one percent of
FBI tapes they recorded and to this day
they're still covering up the other 99
of the tapes and in my life experience
and I know for a fact what's on those
tapes that the side that covers up the
truth is the side that's lying and the
reason they won't play those tapes is
because they're covering up what they
did to me it was a frame up it was no
different from a dirty copper plants a
murder weapon in the glove compartment
to frame an innocent man and they did it
to a governor and they felt emboldened
it was a test case for them and now
they're doing it to an American
president and I love my country with
some bad people in government that did
it to me and I I cry for my country when
I see what's happening now that they
would do something like this to an
American president irrespective of what
party he or she is from that's right
that's right the side that is covering
up evidence is the side that's lying
you really need to just put that on the
refrigerator because that is always true
former Governor Rod Blagojevich joining
us tonight thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight